you've talked to on the show before
about how you came to stand up late and
the jobs you did before you did it
there's a weird kind of connection
between John and Chris because though
yeah I get my dick up on girls no you
you were a louver salesman yeah it was
okay so as I / salesman you've talked
about this ritual you had to go through
yeah yeah I work for the car 17
something like that I work for a company
called their KB cleaners but you're not
to go in in the morning and sing sing
before you go out to tell the world yeah
it was I think was an American concept
that he brought over and and it was just
bizarre using well you know all the
sales figures Commission only so you get
in this room so no listen enthusiast
song sheets they give you song sheets
that it'd be like this is to the tune of
I want to hold your hand by the Beatles
gonna go I wanna sell clean clean
he's honest to god it was just like that
and you come on his thing and he was
always one guy who's always trying get
into the real face because he wants us
to play the drums it was mad cuz as a as
a 17 year old there is a suit that
Apparel's from a friend I thought that
were all jobs were thing Chris Pratt
could have been your boss because you
sort of did this what was a coupons you
were saying yeah coupons yeah I did the
same thing I was like a multi-level
marketing salesman job and we would have
chant in the morning just to clarify
what's the coupon a coupon is like a
it's like a certificate it's a promotion
so we would sell coupons for businesses
in the service industry like Day Spa
type thing a salon to like come and you
know get all dolled up and and and like
get your hair done and your nails done
the gift right you give them a gift you
can give him his gifts yeah but I'll
give you the opportunities that's what
y'all get was not our showers I was
coming yeah I was it was one of those
things where if you work very hard and
you stay enthusiastic and you follow the
steps and you do the chant in the
morning I mean I was so I was hook line
and sinker you know you can open your
own office and like start your own
business and I did I like made it all
the way Oh ice open my own office 19 I
had my own business and and went to a
state in Colorado and I opened my own
office in Denver and put an ad in the
paper the same ad that I had answered
which said you like rock and roll music
you want to make money
is your life [__] you don't read this
I'm gonna blow the office supermodels
life money that's crazy and I also like
rock and roll music quick you haven't
already feel the position have you we
put that same ad in the paper and turned
out like it wasn't all enthusiastic
eighteen year olds like myself who
answered it was like the bottom of the
other people who would I'd send out to
sell and represent my company and they
would like rob a place every morning
tell me how you're feeling it would go
fantastic terrific great oh yeah strong
juice baby sucker I feel wonderful right
on right on right on
juice juice juice juice let's kick some
ass number one we are who's number two
[Applause]
it's really embarrassing to do in front
of a whole room full of Brits here but
I'll try it anyways so it's like so I
want to say like a silly Scot in West
Hollywood which is a an area in LA
that's like a predominantly gay area and
I was there getting hedge getting like
picnic